Kennedy here in Brooklyn there's a plan
to build a massive Whole Foods in this
empty lot people fear it's going to
destroy this bucolic neighborhood
the new grocery store will be
constructed right next door to this
architectural treasure community
activists like Linda Mariano are
outraged part of the original building
was all open space and that's the way it
should remain as open space the building
made use of that open space when it was
operating as part of a stone factory the
factory closed in 1882
Linna Mariano's husband Joe is most
concerned about preserving the area's
natural habitat what kind of a beautiful
tree - we have grown here Delicious
apple tree and they are delicious apple
the Delicious quarter kind red yeah a
Red Delicious apple it stinks now right
where we're sitting you can smell it if
you say you can't I don't know a treat
and I'm here at the Park Slope co-op
this is ground zero for crunchy Brooklyn
style activism Whole Foods has created a
huge controversy these people are pissed
who is coming to town Whole Foods Whole
Foods I don't care one way or another
are you upset that the Whole Foods are
going in down the street no I don't care
I'm thrilled but it's a neighborhood
divided what evidence do you have that I
I've eaten it all foods right yeah I
shop on amazon.com what an outrage I
think that could spell the end of the
coop
no absolutely not nothing could right
nothing absolutely nothing after eight
years of battling opponents like the
Mariano's the new Whole Foods is slated
to open next year it's not over till
it's over
and I believe that Whole Foods still has
some hoops to go through here I'm not
going to mention them right now but
that's in my pocket you know like that
yeah I like your passion you know what I
would do if I could I would bottle it
and sell it at Whole Foods
sorry No thank you